oh all the way up 14 black American
women are now one of the largest groups
ever to climb Mount Kilimanjaro it's the
largest freestanding mountain in the
world and the tallest in Africa they
call themselves sisters to the summit
you are watching the moment when they
reach kilimanjaro's highest point at
more than 19 000 feet earlier this month
that's the length of almost 54 football
fields the women rage in age from 31 to
53 but they don't look a day over 25.
they took an eight-day Journey up and
down the so-called roof of Africa
through a variety of climates two of the
14 women had to turn back mid-trip
because of altitude sickness that would
have been me if I'd been there have been
three of 15 had to turn back in those
altitude sickness but the remaining 12
were happy to say made it to the two
highest Summit points first on CBS
morning's all 14 of these amazing women
are here with us Nate would you do the
introduction oh yeah I got you all right
so it's Christy Christina Danielle
Jennifer Lisa
Naomi Tanisha Taylor Janelle and Erica
yeah that could almost be a song
I know that you guys noticed the DMX we
all got it but Eric I got to start with
you because we have to either thank you
or blame you for that exactly because
you were turning 50. you sent out an
email to all of your friends to a lot of
your friends and you said what I said
hey I have an idea I'd like to climb
Mount Kilimanjaro my dear friend Malak
and I have been talking about this for
five years now let's do it it's my year
of turning 50 and I had a strategy where
I did not want to put any pressure on
anyone because I know that climbing
about Kilimanjaro is not for the faint
of heart yes and 18 people responded 18.
Yes and then you got down to 14. yeah
well Erica just said you all have wanted
to do this for five years why did you
want to do it you know what were you
thinking we have similar travel
sensibilities and we both want to see
the world we're talking about Antarctica
next I mean we want to see the world and
and and we want to discover places and
take ourselves out of our comfort zone
so we've been talking about it but I'll
tell you she told me to plan it and I
never did but when I got her email it
was like instantaneous so Janelle how
did you all train because you all didn't
know each other the the the common Bond
here was Erica so it's not like you all
knew each other or you all live in the
same neighborhood so how did you train
well over the summer a lot of the women
were on Martha's Vineyard so they
started doing hikes together Martha's
Vineyard not the same as McDonald's not
the same yeah but for me I couldn't
travel to Martha's Vineyard so I broke
my boots and in Brooklyn going to Trader
Joe's and Target so we all had to find
our ways to train so whether it was on
the treadmill doing small hikes in New
Jersey or going in Harlem that that was
really just our training strategies now
LaShawn you had to turn back because of
altitude sickness like how tough was
that decision and what does that feel
like for people who don't know yeah well
it wasn't really up to me my uh O2 my
oxygen Nation went down to 56 and
supposed to be at least 100 100 yeah so
it wasn't really up to me the porters
made the decision to carry me down the
mountain we're talking life for Deaf
situations let's begin some of these
things are really dangerous right yeah
it's not like you wimped out it's it was
really very very serious yeah like it
took me I took the other ladies like
seven hours to do it I did it 16 hours
and I was and I kept throwing up I was
really weak when I got back I was like
I'll just sleep and tomorrow I'll I'll
get up and I'll feel better and then my
watch started beeping your heart rate is
high your heart rate is high but you
made the right decision but I look at
all of you today I know Erica you didn't
hike in those shoes would you all
describe yourselves as a high
maintenance group and I'd say that with
great respect and love
for somebody who identifies
would you say you were a high
maintenance group well listen before we
even started the climb we were like do
we have toilets do we have showers right
we need that we need at least three of
each uh to do this though we did abandon
them because the showers the reward was
not better than the effort of actually
going to a shower in rocks and dirt and
being cold
um and but the other thing that I think
was a game changer not just because
we're high maintenance but because but
it helped us the strategy to Summit and
also we bonded with the porters the
borders supporters on the mountains how
does that work order so we decided that
we wanted to give ourselves the best
chance to Summit and so we decided we
weren't going to carry our day packs we
were just going to roll with our
trekking poles and our water so our
snacks our first date everything went
with our personal Porter so somebody's
carrying it someone's caring which was
very unique on the mountain because
everybody who is climbing the mountain
they're in it salted Earth kind of
people granola and we were the only
group we were the only groups that had
someone walking beside us carrying our
backpack how many Porters did you have
72.
we made it we made it to them
hey were they carrying the bags of
carrying y'all
I love it so you guys made it to the top
this month or last month two weeks ago
if anyone's still sore yes yeah
absolutely
closed captioning not available
but let's do rapid fire questions
because I want to get everybody involved
uh yay or nay thumbs up or down was the
climb the most challenging thing you've
ever done oh
oh Erica says no okay did you ever want
to give up at any point
yes yes
did you make lifelong friendships
ah would you do it again with your
spouse or significant other
everybody
[Applause]
because of the climb or because of the
significant others I think we know the
answer to that okay and when you came
back LaShawn you all had set up a thing
what did you do when you reached the top
what did you do when you reached the
very top we we danced we had lunch and
then we did a tick tock
last yes or no should Nate climb a
mountain and get into the wide world of
the outdoors yeah yeah
yeah all right looks like we got our
next story thanks for setting that up
Tony and we appreciate y'all thank you
so much
next adventure sisters to the summit
we'll be right back yeah